the desperation in Puerto Rico is
growing by the day
Washington is boosting its efforts to
help the victims of Hurricane Maria but
the islands electrical grid is still
down one week after the storm thousands
are stranded at airports and roads are
clogged with debris food water and fuel
are all in short supply at least 16
deaths are blamed on Maria and it's
aftermath officials worried the death
toll will rise drastically if emergency
supplies aren't distributed soon
now FEMA has more than 2,100 federal
officials on the ground in Puerto Rico
sixteen Navy and Coast Guard ships are
there to deliver supplies ten more or on
the way
David beg no is at a hospital in San
Juan with the latest David good morning
good morning here in Puerto Rico even
the hospitals need help this is the mice
throw in San Juan there's only one
operating room that's functioning right
now surgeries are being prioritized only
the ICU has air conditioning the rest of
the floors are dark patients have been
moved together children and adults being
treated in the same area there's a
generator that is powering whatever
lights they do have here and the mayor
of San Juan says if they run out of fuel
at this hospital they're gonna run out
of life we have married 20 years hey
soos gotta say sotto is battling stage
four cancer his wife a breast cancer
survivor herself brought him to the
hospital de maestro the night hurricane
Maria hit me here it's very difficult is
there no air condition just one
generator keeps two floors operational
but fuel is low and frustrations are
high I think that abandon that's medical
director of Aronica Rodriguez who says
only one of the hospital's five
operating rooms is usable what I fear
most is that a patient can die because
of this only 21 of the 69 hospitals in
Puerto Rico have power or fuel this is
the time for action San Juan mayor you
lean crew
is frustrated with what she says is a
slow response from FEMA they're waiting
for their marching orders now you're in
an emergency if you don't do then
hundreds of lives will be lost hundreds
of lives will be lost
temperatures have reached 90 degrees
nearly half of the island has no water
Alex de la compra is the FEMA
coordinator here on the ground in Puerto
Rico the people are receiving their food
and water a lot of things are being done
by FEMA I believe you I have no reason
not to believe you but why don't we see
it where are the photos where are the
videos this is the worst catastrophic
disaster in Puerto Rico and we have been
engaged in their response operations now
we're going to make sure that we publish
everything that we're doing mr. delicate
old us he would set us up with one of
the FEMA crews and allow us to go out
and document the work they're doing
we'll keep you posted on whether or not
that happens the US military is sending
a naval ship a floating hospital it's
called the Comfort it's coming to Puerto
Rico but it might take three to five
days to get here and Nora the rapper
Pitbull did something very nice he sent
his private jet down here to Puerto Rico
to take cancer patients back to the
mainland people who so desperately
needed treatment all right David Pegg no
they're reporting in Puerto Rico thank
you so much